seit vielen jahrzehnten suchen wir
menschen nach außerirdischem leben und
das auf unterschiedlichste art und weise
eine idee ist es botschaften ins all zu
schicken und mögliche lebewesen dort
über unsere existenz zu informieren
mitte oktober wurde jetzt eine
radiowellen botschaften an den planeten
g j 273 b gesendet außerirdisches leben
dort scheint sehr wahrscheinlich was der
inhalt der botschaft war und warum
außerirdische lebensform wohl schon im
juni 2000 43 antworten könnten jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
eine botschaft an mögliche außerirdische
zu schicken diese idee ist nicht neu wir
haben ja hier über die arecibo botschaft
berichtet die mitte november 1974 von
arecibo radioteleskop in puerto rico ins
all gesendet wurde oder auch die voyager
golden record also daten platten mit
infos in form von bildern und audios die
im jahr 1977 an bord von watcher eins
und zwei als botschaften an
außerirdische lebensform im universum
adressiert worden waren darauf unter
anderem zu entdecken
grußbotschaften den 55 verschiedenen
sprachen und musik von wolfgang amadeus
mozart
jetzt bekommen die außerirdischen schon
wieder post von der erde die adresse
luiten stern ein rotes werkstatt in etwa
12,35 lichtjahren entfernung zu ihm
gehören mindestens zwei planeten einer
von ihnen geo 273 b ist theoretisch von
außerirdischen lebensformen bewohnbar
abgeschickt wurde die radiowellen
botschaft von einem ice kette rada im
norwegischen troms initiiert von der
organisation meti international
messaging tool extraterrestrial
intelligence in kooperation mit dem sohn
a music festival und dem institute of
space studies of catalonia und zwar im
oktober genauer am 16 17 und 18
und zwar dreimal fast die gleiche
nachricht inhaltlich unterscheidet sie
sich allerdings stark von den bisherigen
nachrichten die aktuellen botschaften
haben laut einem interview von space.com
mit dem medi präsidenten das war koch
nicht in anspruch enzyklopädisch zu sein
stattdessen hat man sich auf
mathematische und wissenschaftliche
inhalte konzentriert da glaswerk koch
sagt weiter meine befürchtung ist dass
wenn man versucht alles zu kommunizieren
ob man am ende gar nichts sagt und so
müssen die potenziellen außerirdischen
empfänger sich mit unserer idee von
mathematik herumschlagen
denn die nachricht beginnt mit einer
demonstration wie wir zählen dann folgen
die grundrechenarten so wie
beispielsweise der satz des pythagoras
die nachricht erklärt außerdem auch noch
die speziellen wellen aus denen sie
besteht und das alles sollte nicht zu
viel verlangt sein wenn die
außerirdischen es ebenso wie wir
geschafft haben sollten ein
radioteleskop zu bauen dann wird die
nachricht an georg 273 b aber auch noch
richtig
denn dann gibt es neben dem
komplizierten mathematischen
berechnungen noch musik und außerdem
eine art deadline denn die botschaft
verrät den potenziellen außerirdischen
lebensform auch wann sie uns am besten
fall antworten sollen nämlich dann wenn
wir hinhören und zwar am 21 juni 2043
dann also könnten wir also post von geo
273 bekommen und natürlich gibt es auch
hier kritiker wie schon immer seitdem
wir versuchen mit außerirdischen
lebensform kontakt aufzunehmen einige
befürchten eine invasion von höher
entwickelten lebewesen die wir durch
solche nachrichten auf den plan gerufen
haben die unsere existenz also vorher
gar nicht auf dem schirm hatten physiker
stephen hawking ist da zum beispiel
einer der kritiker dass bei koch hält
das aber für unsinn es fällt mir
wirklich schwer mir ein szenario
auszumalen in dem eine zivilisation rund
um den nöten stern zwar die fähigkeit
entwickelt haben könnten zur erde zu
gelangen und uns zu bedrohen dennoch
nicht schon längst unseren bisherigen
unfreiwilligen tv radiosignale empfang
als solche erkannt haben könnte mit i
will also weitermachen zum einen will
die organisation botschaften auch an
andere sterne verschicken und zum
anderen soll auch geo 273 b noch einmal
kontaktiert werden
eine zweite nachricht soll im april
gesendet werden sie soll erklären wie
wir menschen musik verstehen
außerirdische sind ja hier bei pixum
immer wieder ein thema wenn ihr kein
video dazu verpassen wollt dann sollten
wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke nur dann
verpasst ja auch kein video hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken aliens der
erste kontakt sehr interessant ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran